oh
[Music]
dude doing it to you can we talk about
something for a second can we talk about
how i went to 24-hour fitness last night
and turns out they're not actually open
24 hours right god i was in such a bad
mood
i was in such a bad mood that i wanted
to get up and work out for the second
time in a
single day which sometimes i do lately
i've been going in the morning
for a lift and a sauna and then i'll
lift with brendan and i didn't get a
chance to
do that before i did deadlifts with
brendan i feel like i didn't get enough
cardio i didn't get enough
sauna in because it's been this very
relaxing
detoxifying distressing
i don't believe in the word detoxifying
get all the toxins out what toxins name
one toxin i'll always remember this
conversation that adam corolla had with
dr drew on love line
where doc uh adam corolla claimed that
pooping the act of pooping
removes the toxins from your body and dr
drew said name a single toxin that
pooping removes from your body turns out
he couldn't name one because that's not
how toxins work right they're not being
removed
uh from
your body via your poop because then
they would reabsorb back into your
intestine
on the way out right can we agree on
that so
the sauna just makes you feel there's
lots of benefits the sauna
has exercise mimicking effects
it dilates your blood vessels it reduces
stress it preps your entire body to feel
more pleasure
because after a while you release
something called i believe it's called
dinorphins don't quote me on that but
it's like the dark matter version of
endorphins right
the uh what was wario why it's like the
bizarro world you know right is that
yeah wario wario yeah wario's evil
mario's good wario's evil endorphins are
good
dinorphones are bad but when you sit in
the sauna and they get released turns
out it preps your endorphin receptors
to receive the endorphins and feel
better as you release endorphins
throughout the day you're re-sensitized
to them so anyway i had a few moments
where you know you ever check in with
yourself and you're like damn i'm in a
bad mood
um
on the uh
i'm going oh
it was three things in a row i'm trying
to collect my thoughts and what were the
moments from like oh damn i have no
patience tonight for these kind of
interactions and maybe it was because it
was close to 10 p.m
and do you lose patience throughout the
day i assume so for various things
but the first thing was as i'm walking
oh i'm walking over to get a bottle of
water before i go into the sauna and
it's like 9 49
you know i'm like oh i have 10 minutes
to use the sun and get out because
apparently 24-hour fitness closes at 10
pm so that was really the first thing is
that i'm on the stairmaster
after doing a weight workout
did some shoulders did some arms
and
i'm on the stairmaster and i see a guy
like walking through the gym with a
whiteboard sign you know and i couldn't
see what was written by it but he works
there and he's doing this so you have to
assume oh he's telling everybody the gym
is closing right the 24-hour fitness is
closing at 10 p.m
um
so that was the first thing around my
god why are you paying for a 24-hour
fitness membership if it closes at 10 pm
i get it there's all sorts of
considerations for that you shouldn't
take it out on the people who work there
however
i can have the thought that this is
stupid right and i should you know be
paying whatever the percentage of
the monthly membership that i paid for a
24-hour gym
if you're taking six hours off of that
give me that proportional discount okay
i'm not going to take it up with them
i'm going to take it up with upper
management perhaps the ceo depending on
if i can get to him or not i do have a
lot of connections in this fitness
industry i'm kind of a big deal
but
i opted to keep it to myself but then i
go
to go buy some water i haven't had water
i'm noticing how thirsty i'm i'm not
going to sit in the sauna for 10 minutes
without any water so i go to the front
desk to get some water and i go i go i'm
like reaching in the refrigerator to
pull out the biggest bottle of water i
can find he's like oh actually the
register is closed already
that's one of those things where you
know maybe normally at 6am i go that's
okay no problem it's not your fault
me being rude is me just saying nothing
and turning back around like not
acknowledging the thing you know it's
like oh you can't do that i'm like
and then i just walk away without making
eye contact eh is that rude a little bit
but
frustrating because it's like hey the
thing's open you know the register's
closed maybe keep it open until the
whole store the whole
business is closed because why can't i
buy stuff on the way out or 10 minutes
or 15 minutes before the gym closes does
it make any sense
to me seems like you're probably just
making some shortcuts for oh we want to
get out early so we're going to start
shutting down oh yeah the bench isn't
open because
oh yeah you can't use weights anymore
because we're putting all the weights
back and we want to get out here at 10
pm so at 9 pm actually you you have to
start
you know
only doing cardio because everything's
cut off so then i go into the sauna
right
that's multiple offenses in a row we
have
and the guy goes
i walk in and he's in the hot tub the
way it's set up it's like a sauna
um
you can everybody can walk in it's not
in the men's or women's locker room they
both feed out into this one
uh glorious area where there's a sauna
there's the steam room and there's a hot
tub that's elevated but like you know
hot tubs make noise everything around
here makes noise so all i hear is like
someone looking in my direction going
like
i'm like what and he's like have you
ever thought about acting
and i was like i can't have this
conversation right now i'm sorry
um or i said yes and he started to say
something i was like yes i have thought
about acting or i said you know yes i am
an actor and he starts going like oh
wait like i'm like i can't i'm sorry i
can't have this conversation and just
walk away
have you ever had that car like it's
like i like normally you know
catch me at 7 30 a.m i'm i'm full of uh
life energy we can have that
conversation about me being an actor but
not and also you're in a time crunch but
you know
these are things that i almost feel like
a dick about
have you ever had that conversation
where you're just like i can't do this
right now um not specifically that i
mean i don't think i'm i don't have as
uh much of a look as you do well we'll
say i'm not getting stopped and going
yeah yeah i'm just you should be the
next aquaman yeah i'm just a little guy
we don't really get somebody you're like
have you ever thought about being the
internet's most handsome podcast
producer yeah no oh my god
i just can't right
yeah
so annoying
what a diva sound like huh kinda and
then and then the final thing was i know
i'm just expressing this all to you
because it's like you know these are not
normal reactions for me and it's okay so
what's going on are you all right mark
what's going on buddy let's talk just me
and you here
um
you know i'm fine unpacking that but
also it's just like
i do you know
i think
of myself as
being frustrated by a lot of like
sometimes i'll express frustration to
people or like express that in sarcasm
like oh my god you're mean i'm like oh
no this like i hold back 99 of that you
know like i could be a lot meaner
it could be mute if i wanted to uh you
know
he'd say stuff like that but you know
it's like when you give somebody a
little hint and they're like oh my god
you know especially when it's somebody
who's like wait you don't value that
you're mean to me all the time or you're
sarcastic or you you know
you seemingly do that but then you can't
take a you know just that little bit of
euro medicine but then the final thing
that capped it off was i'm coming out of
the sauna at 10 and putting my like
shirt back on and the same guy at the
front desk was like oh the register's
closed i'm like
cool you know uh he's now in the sauna
and he's like you ready to go man
and i'm like
yeah
like
as
i'm walking away i'm like i wish i would
have said no i'm just putting my clothes
back on after the sauna so i can go back
inside
which would have been
you know that borders on dickishness but
i totally would have justified it in
that moment
um
this is why i talk crap by the way to
people on the internet because
if you think of a line and then don't
say it
you're more likely or i'm more likely to
be haunted by the fact oh i should have
said that right so it's like i get it
out of my system and it's easier for me
to deal with the guilt of possibly being
perceived as a jerk
than it is for me to deal
uh with
the
regret of not having said that jerkish
thing all right can we get on to some
more positive things such as for example
the fact that i was in a pose down with
luke rockhold and how grateful i am just
for the fact that
i have giant muscles no you know you
want to talk about being ripped luke
rock hold probably
seven percent body fat people ask about
this like you know manny fan pretended
to you look at this
you can see all of his muscles you can
see all of his veins and i'm simply not
that lean not that i look bad but you
know this is a guy who's doing a ton of
cardio his diet's on point he's watching
everything and you can just see it he
has very very little visible body fat
and all these sort of things like look
at the back of his shoulders right in
that pose look at me i look puffy and
watery and that's okay i'm not mad at my
own physique but these are the
substantive differences that you see
where you can see like striations in
your shoulder you can see
more vascularity you can see like when
he bends over like that and you see the
little wrinkle in his abdominal like
skin you know below that's because
there's no fat there right if you're
just puffy in that area it's not going
to wrinkle in the same way but
you know for those people ask what are
you like eight percent no that's eight
percent that's seven percent body fat
you know another and it's really cool
just let me give praise for a second to
thick boy studios and brendan shop and
these events where
i can meet guys like luke rockhold some
of these fighters it's a really cool
thing to meet them in a casual
environment and then have them be like
oh yeah i've seen you on whatever on
brendan's instagram or whatever like you
know that'll never stop being cool to me
that you watch somebody fight you know
somebody's a celebrity and then they say
oh you know i recognize you from this
like i was hanging out with michael
chandlin today on the food truck diary
is gonna be an amazing episode because
he's just
also like some other fighters that have
met like alexander volkonovsky these
guys are really thoughtful he's really
intelligent really thoughtful really
charismatic
and really well spoken somebody who
definitely has a
uh you know a bright bright future in
broadcasting every wants to do that but
as a guest he's just super entertaining
and him and brendan have great chemistry
and
you know we did a little funny little
gimmick that i'm not going to spoil
but you get to you know then play with
them during the episode and have them do
things that are out of the ordinary that
make for really great content so i come
up and talk to him and he's like oh yeah
you have your own podcast too don't you
and i'm like
oh my god michael chandler's a huge
haters will say man it's
crazy it's true though um you know i'm
not saying that but i am saying it's
cool to be recognized by a guy who you
know i look up to him he's an incredible
athlete he's somebody who i watch on tv
he's an absolute savage and a very
intelligent guy
and i think he lives his life with
integrity and adopts kids
because he's a good person
okay
and
that's just a really cool example to set
for the entire world you know what i
mean if everybody acted like michael
chandler
uh you know the world would be a better
place and a far more violent place
because he's a professional fighter so
if everybody was sparring and getting
into fights all the time sure it would
be more violent
but there would be less black children
who didn't have families okay so let's
just end it there
another thing that happened to me really
recently that i thought was cool is you
know sometimes look i'm always talking
about the dudes that i admire and run
into but sometimes you run into girls
like lean beef patty
isn't she cute isn't she buff isn't she
amazing now this is somebody who
like
there's a difference between for me just
being like oh i follow this girl on
instagram and she's hot and therefore i
like her she just seems like she has a
great personality she seems another
person who seems thoughtful intelligent
she's got this
amazing like you know sort of beautiful
nerdy girl next door look going on but
also she makes these really funny look
could you click on that one with the
mask on
like i also just think her content is
really creative in simple ways like
she's making the stuff in a room
watching movies together
and that turns into
watching anime together oh
this is the one i was thinking of per se
but
let's click on any random video that you
see
there we go oh this is her
transformation yes
so again nothing wrong with her in these
first few pics but then we see how
jacked she is now she has super
prominent abs
she has amazing muscular development and
i just think it all still looks
very feminine you know not that she
needs my approval of whether she looks
feminine enough or not but it's a great
example of this thing that women are
always afraid of like
i'm going to get too buff and bulky and
you know not look at this girl has
very large developed muscles really
prominent abdominals and she still looks
very feminine
and attractive in my opinion and i just
think she's a great ambassador for the
fitness industry anything i watch from
her that involves like form
um
you know or stretching or anything like
that i'm like oh she does stuff that i
can watch and learn from because she
gives great tutorials and i think she's
sending a great message to the people
who are following her and she does have
a very big following so shout out to
lean beef patty she said she'd come on
the show i hope we make that happen
because i would just love to hear more
about her as an individual as a person
as a human being
there we go
she's got swag like what you know
there's oh there we go that's what i was
thinking of
[Laughter]
that sped up little dance at the end
it's as simple as creative
speaking of other people
who i look up to
in the fitness industry
recently had a chance to work out with
michael hearn
michael hearn is a
legend in the fitness community he's a
former
uh mr universe he's a power lifter he's
uh a
judoka a judoka i don't know what the
male term is i only know it via ronda
rousey people say she's a judoka is
there a male term that i don't know who
knows who cares he does judo he does
sports he grew up playing football
and meeting him in person
i guess what comes across because i've
recently started watching let's say in
the last
two or three years i'd consumed more of
his content and everybody knows michael
hearn even if you don't know the name
you know him from fitness magazines if
you're around my age or whatever but
he's like literally the most
photographed like fitness model he's
been on the most covers of say muscle
and fitness or flex magazine
you couldn't like turn around in a gnc
in the 90s without seeing michael hurt
it was like he was it's almost like he
was like a composite of every fitness
model ever born was like here we go with
this guy with the perfect physique and
the perfect face for fitness modeling is
here and you know he almost doesn't look
real
now i know there's a lot of controversy
around whether or not he takes creatine
but
he told me in person that he has never
taken creatine and never would therefore
um i believe him you know you got to
take him at face value i think he's a
non-creatine user
and
we'll just have to leave it at that is
he the dude from that football movie is
the program
no
he's not latimer although they kind of
like they're roughly the same size he's
a big dude he's also like
i think he's either approaching 50 or in
his 50s and can
the most impressive oh look at that
could you click on that behind the neck
press with three wheels like
just his
strength is insanely impressive i've
seen videos of him repping 455 on
incline super controlled right and again
anybody this age like let's i don't know
how old ronnie coleman is but like
you see guys who train really hardcore
throughout their lives and eventually if
you're not using great form or you don't
take care of injuries um it's going to
catch up with you oh there's a video of
him let's check out that one the
american gladiator one do you see where
he's pressing the guy up against there i
also grew up on mike
watching american glasses that's where i
recognize yes right
and so you can kind of see we gotta tell
me a little bit of stories about some of
these guys on there i'm not gonna name
any names but he would talk about how
like yeah these some of these guys or
girls like looked really good but they
weren't necessarily athletes so you
dominate them in these you know there
were like there was this performance
aspect to it so
if you've actually played football
before you know or know how to do
martial arts it's a huge
advantage so
um but in person mike i just found to
have a fantastic sense of humor and he's
like a guy's guy you know what i mean
he's like giving everybody crap and um
just reminds me
you know of a guy i might have played
football with or a football coach or
something like that and i think we need
more guys like michael hernan also
i'm gonna have you watch this video in a
second but i was just going to say that
the instruction that he can give you
like the notes that he can give you
it's really true like i feel like i
lifted with him twice with uh you know
having been invited by my buddy griffin
who started working out with him
griffin gaines chiropractor um
[Music]
he said oh yeah you should come work out
with us
so i joined their crew we filmed some
content and
the nuanced specificity of the notes he
was able to give me on basic movements
that you take for granted like a lateral
raise you know or a hyper extension
you know
on a shoulder press these very simple
movements that you're like oh i know how
to do this and of course i'm also
somebody who goes like i'm always trying
to learn right i
have some degree of mastery but you can
always learn
mike is a real
expert
in the field of bodybuilding he's not
just somebody who has a really nice
physique which you can achieve a really
nice physique without being also an
amazing coach but mike somebody who has
both
because
he can take his knowledge and he can
transfer it to anybody he can show you
the little tweak the little thing he can
communicate it to the individual which i
think is a really important skill so i
felt like i leveled just a couple
training sessions with him and i hope i
do more but he'll level you up right
and really just a phenomenal coach on
top of all those things i said earlier
let's check out this video because it's
inspirational at the end of the day
dude
yeah
there's me doing front raises
in the shadows dramatic music
this dude's gigantic and if you're pro
there is modeling this for me you know
i'm doing like a
basically a shrug right there i'm seated
with a couple dumbbells with my back
bent over this is another thing where
it's like oh i know how to shrug and
then he showed me a whole new way that
really targets my traps
and i've never done before and it's
harder than it looks and it's something
that i take and i'm gonna
keep using in my real life
okay so enough of me blowing michael
hearn let's get on the liver king meme
of the week huh yeah
mark do you use kratom
you know casey earlier we were talking
about um the things that i take before
the podcast to really get my brain fully
activated and i said i'm going to keep
it a secret and then tell you
on air well
secret's going to get revealed right now
it's happy hippocratum and i get that
happy hippocratum from happyhippo
herbals.com and when i buy it i use
promo code thickpoi with three cs
because
it gives me a 20 discount off my
purchase not just that one time yes but
can i use that promo code the thing is
you can use it your friends can use it
your mom can use it if she's into kratom
why not why not put that stocking
stuffer that stocking stuffer under her
tree this christmas yes but mark can the
fans use it oh funny you should ask the
fans can absolutely use that literally
anybody who has a computer and a mouth
can use their fingers
to type
promo code thickboy into
happyhipporbibles.com
yes but that we could only use that one
time it's funny you should ask that but
you would assume that sometimes you do
these one-time promo deals but in this
case you can use it for eternity
hey cute top mark you know it's funny
that you should mention my cute top
casey because it actually is from
oakenstone now i know you've seen the
ads on my instagram page you see the
clothes when i wear them on this podcast
on the fighter and the kid in my real
life and you might be thinking yourself
mark do you just have a pump right now
or is it the shirt or what it just seems
like whatever size i'm at
this stone shirt hugs those pythons
perfectly and i know what you're
thinking too mark it's the summer
how can i get a shirt that looks like
it's made of wool
that must be super hot well it's not and
i also
don't have to have slacks to pair these
with okay you don't need to be some uh a
wealthy
uh
men's fashion
advocate right because that's the thing
men's fashion advocate you just have to
be somebody who has i don't know
thick boy athletic pants on right wow
look at these it's just great pants okay
i wear them with athletic shorts
athletic pants i paired them with all
sorts of things because they just seem
to go with whatever and because they're
built with the athlete in mind well
guess what athletic pants and athletic
shorts seem to pair very well with them
so if you're an athlete if you look like
an athlete if you want to look like an
athlete if you have a boyfriend or
husband who fancies himself an athlete
or prospective athlete go to
oakenstoneclothing.com and use promo
code hella for 10 off at checkout and
say what's up to ricardo
he's my boy
so the caption here
is uh intern mr johnson i have a great
idea for a video hear me out you know
those fake balls the guys uh with small
penises put on their huge trucks well
and then the video is liver king
sitting in a tire at a giant tire as he
pulls the truck to himself
and the truck doesn't have truck nuts
the truck has actual nuts
he takes them off
and he eats them
the liver king once again is eating nuts
i'd love to see the behind the scenes
i'd love to see him be like yep you know
this is because i eat stuff of course it
doesn't taste great sometimes you don't
always
feel in the mood to eat chicken and rice
and other foods that are healthy but you
choke it down eating raw testicles takes
that whole idea to another level right
because you psychologically have to get
over it in addition to the fact that
you're eating raw meat that i have to
assume tastes disgusting
but that's why we love the liver king
long live the liver king you might say
a lot of people have been asking me okay
so
a few people have actually been asking
me
because i know i say that in jest but
sometimes people
do actually ask me things enough to the
point where it warrants a general
response
how do i lose fat right i saw a really
interesting video and this is a great
channel by the way
um in addition to checking out mike
o'hearn's youtube page which i think if
you're into bodybuilding and learning
some tricks
about how to build muscle in a
bodybuilding context the best ways to
attack a target muscle group go check
out michael hern's youtube age you're
definitely going to learn something
if you're interested in
the science and chemistry and
um nuts and bolts of like bodybuilding
prep you know if you're trying to like
do a show or learn about cycles or
uh you know learn some
some nuts and bolts tricks like carb
cycling and how to cut and like
there's this great youtube channel that
i've discovered that kind of is in the
vein of these guys that i really like
like vigorous steve and leon longevity
and derek more plates more dates um
this is a guy who's
his delivery might be a little bit drier
but
he's got his i believe he's in his 40s
and he's a masters bodybuilder
he's a competitive bodybuilder he's
giant he's ripped and you know one of
these bodybuilding nerds guys but he'll
break down insulin for you he'll break
down his experiences with nandralone or
these you know how to plan out for
example an entire year
of cycling like down to the week and
down to the compound which is very very
useful for people because this is
something that i always tell people that
come to me like i want to run you know
eight weeks of this sarm
and i'm like
tell me why because you're going to go
exactly back to the same place from
which you started at the end of those
eight weeks i don't see the purpose of
doing these little things unless you're
fully aware of the fact that
it's not going to be a jump start to
something greater it's much more likely
going to be something that
ultimately leaves you in a much worse
off position down the road and i'm not
talking about immediately after you stop
i'm talking about like a year from now
you would have just benefited from
training naturally right
so if you're going to take that plunge
i'll preach over and over and over again
you want to have at least a year-long
plan so this guy breaks it down to like
the training blocks you know like
starting off with 250 tests for four
weeks
and pushing it hard you know and then
taking a weak deload and then upping it
to you know 400 and then pushing it
for this many weeks and that's in your
bulk you know so he's giving you a
really specific
applicable practical template
another video that i watched that brings
me to this topic
is all the ways that you can lose fat
right
um
so
he goes through all the things that you
can take you know for example like
testosterone
it's not going to help you lose fat in
and of itself but it's going to create
an environment
in which you're
more anabolic and you're more likely to
lose fat right and not store fat
it goes through
you know how growth hormone does that
how you can use insulin to that how can
you use uh carb cycling in the food that
you eat in order to deplete yourself and
get to you know use up deplete yourself
of glycogen to the point that you're
using fat as a fuel source right
he goes through you know appetite
suppressants because there's only a few
you know you could only
there's only a finite number of pathways
by which you can lose fat some of those
include you know
gw
um aka cartering gw in a series of
numbers like five zero eight five one or
whatever
and that is something that it's a
non-stimulant fat burner it causes
an increase in lipolysis or a burning of
the fat an increase in fat metabolism
[Music]
s9009 is another one of those
non-stimulant fat burners if you're
looking at stimulant fat burners right
it's
clenbuterol or t3 which is a thyroid
hormone um you know but all those
basically act on you to increase your
body temperature so even if you're
taking you know something says like it's
a fat burner or it's a green tea pill or
something that makes you
feel warmer you're just increasing your
metabolism right just like you you feel
warmer when you're doing cardio right
um
you can also
suppress your appetite using things like
nicotine gum
there's also a new research there's a
chemical out now that's prescribed to
clinically obese people i believe it's
called
cemagletide i'll have to look it up in a
second but um
you know
this is something that it's an injection
that you can take to suppress your
appetite because most people struggle
with that it's like i'm hungry all the
time
paul talks about the two different
hormones that control hunger
leptin and ghrelin grenlin is something
that makes you hungry you might be
taking a growth hormone agonist
such as
mk667 and
that is
allegedly something that increases
ghrelin so even though you might be
taking it to lose fat because it
releases growth hormone you end up
inadvertently increasing your own
appetite and eating yourself out of this
um
but
also obese people this is something i
learned from the video if you're
chronically obese
those hormones are likely to be very off
and you can be desensitized to the
hormone leptin which is what gives you
that feeling of satiation you know the
feeling that you're full
if you're morbidly obese and chronically
so you're probably just never feeling
full and that could be a completely
hormonal thing um
you know but if you're blaming your
thyroid or whatever it's you know in
most of these cases it's like you're
eating too much so we talked about the
example before the woman who's like i
don't know what's going on i'm only
eating 200 calories a day
and then on the you know that one day i
eat whatever i want well if you're
eating 20 000 calories it doesn't matter
what you the rest of the week because
all these things that all these roads
they are ways to lose weight but
ultimately you can't break the laws of
thermodynamics
you have to expend
more energy more caloric energy than you
take in otherwise you don't lose any
weight and any of those examples that i
used you can use nicotine gum to
suppress your appetite but if you still
eat yourself into a caloric surplus it
doesn't matter you can't lose fat
so
all these things are tools
in your toolkit to lead you to being in
a caloric deficit
but there's no magic thing and that's
what people always seem to want to know
is what's the thing what can i take to
lose fat
you can take anything as long as it
leads to you eating less food
than
you need
throughout the day to burn to keep your
body going right because then you're
gonna use your body's own fuel sources
and that's the only way to lose fat
ultimately so you can know how to
manipulate that and learn all these
different ways to do it but it doesn't
matter if you're eating ten thousand
calories a day okay so maybe put the
fork down fatty
jesus christ
speaking of eating
my healthy chef harley for the week is
trifecta meals now i'm not plugging them
but i did do a sketch with noel leyva
and she gave me some trifecta meals
because the ad was for trifecta she
threw some my weight and i just thought
about how
goddamn daddy it is so easy
to throw one of these meals in the
microwave
and not think about it and and the
reason that we do meal prep and stuff
like that is because
you just don't want to be thinking about
it you don't want to catch yourself
either not eating because you don't have
something available because then if you
put that meal off too long you're going
to be more likely to go oh well
mcdonald's is right here i feel like i'm
in an emergency
and i want to eat right now
and yes i got mcdonald's the other day
but once i stopped eating mcdonald's
it's over for you hoes and i stand by
that statement bubble guts bubble guts
bubble gets me over here is what they
used to call me two days ago
and
the
you know having a meal if you can't
afford meal prep i'm sorry be less broke
but if you can do it if you can afford
the chicken pound if you could afford
some way to give yourself protein i mean
last night i made like four pounds of
ground turkey in a giant pan just to
have it on hand because that's always
the limiting factor is like you know
you're sitting down to chew something if
you combine
ground turkey or any meat that you have
pre-cooked and one of these little rice
bowls that i get from costco or a potato
a potato takes five six minutes in the
microwave you
should never be more than 10 minutes
away from a cooked meal
that gives you protein and a healthy
carb a potatoes high volume so
i feel like that's just a key to any
time i've ever gotten lean it's always
always always predicated on having
at least a couple meals a day
that i can just grab quickly that have
adequate protein and a good carb right
um lately the thing hat for me has been
if i eat protein pancakes in the morning
because it's like a hundred grand like
you know i keep adding [ __ ] to it i've
been adding seeds and you know hemp
seeds flax seeds chia seeds
those healthy polyunsaturated fats
do help satiation and keep me full for a
really long period of time so i don't
hit the afternoon and i'm suddenly
starving right so it helps you make
better decisions but i'm getting 100
grams of protein and right off the bat
you know and if you can do that
consistently you just want to catch
yourself because one thing to like be in
a deficit and you're eating nothing sure
but then you're more likely to waste
that muscle so if you
can just consistently get
at least a couple meals in right it's
like hitting that 80 mark that i always
talk about it's like you don't you know
you don't need to kill yourself every
single day at the gym but if you can
commit to going like i'm going to hit
you know that 75 80 intensity mark at
least every day
then a couple days out of the week
you're going to do really good you know
if you hit that 80 of the diet mark and
then a cup you know one day you fast or
something like that chances are you're
probably going to be in a pretty good
position over the course of a year right
you're going to be better off than
trying to yo-yo diet or do something
extreme and and lose a lot of muscle and
hate your life really because that's
what it comes down to you don't want to
feel like you're punishing yourself you
don't want to feel like this is my diet
and i hate everything i eat
sustainability is the key like we talked
about with mr aquino body
okay before we get on to the fun stuff i
just want to talk about this this is the
last serious ass thing that i talk
about um
hella depressing
we're going to look at caleb von moger
so
last time we talked you know
he
survived this uh horrific accident
i guess you could maybe call it
something that's not an accident because
he willfully jumped out of a window
right but it was at the tail end of a
lot of erratic behavior this has been
going on for quite a bit of time spurred
by injuries so perhaps you know it's
spurred on by mental health issues
depression from not being able to train
or compete or do the things that he
loves to do because of these injuries
and you replace that with substance
abuse and dependence and things spiral
from there to a point where he did in
fact check into rehab and things
seem to be going in the right direction
but then he checks himself out of rehab
early after i think only a couple weeks
now
what i wanted to comment
on this uh was regarding
differing perspectives on
what you can do as a family member or a
friend
nick tragilly
um
was somebody who came out and said
he runs bodybuilding in bs it's kind of
like a body he's like
nick's strength and power bodybuilding
and nbs but he is a bodybuilder nick's
strengths and power he's not a
bodybuilder and that would be one
critique is like he doesn't really know
anything about anabolics
um
in some of the nuts and bolts that you
might only get from actually like doing
bodybuilding
in an enhanced fashion so
i like to go to nick because
he has great sources and knows what's
going on in the fitness community from
people who he's worked with and who
trust him and he also has the
perspective of somebody who's like
won national competitions in
bodybuilding and then gave it up because
he was like that you know i've been
doing this since 15 he's been in hand
since he was 15 he can give you a lot of
perspective on that of what it's like
for many of these bodybuilders who start
super young
and um you know abuse steroids and now
he's taking trt and hgh and has a more
balanced approach to life but i think
his perspective is interesting however
sometimes i think he talks out of his
ass
in this particular instance i think he's
blaming
he's like caleb you don't have any
friends or family who can like jump in
and stop you from you know smoking meth
i don't think it's that easy i don't
think that you know if you're
good friends with a drug addict short of
organizing
an intervention and even in that case
you know you would feel like you'd have
to have hit a rock bottom and you can
get some bitter to rehab and that's
still difficult but you know you can't
necessarily intervene as an individual
and i've seen that before and friends
that i've had
as an individual you're often just
working to push that person away to
other people who will enable them so i
think the point of an intervention from
my ignorant perspective is to cut off
sort of the angles of retreat for that
person so that they don't have
you know somebody they can feel like
they can go like to that person and turn
away from you and you know
they have to feel like this is the only
option that i have available for me
because all my normal sources of
enabling
aren't there
i don't think it's that easy just to
provide you know like shame to somebody
just to say like you shouldn't be doing
this i'm gonna smack
i'm gonna smack the crack pipe out of
your hand right
it's not how it works um
and it is a little bit tricky when you
have a celebrity type situation or maybe
somebody's on payroll or whatever it's
like yeah
you're not in a sort of status position
to
cut that person off from drugs or
whatever but that's
that's my perspective on it i'm inviting
you guys to comment down below on have
you ever known anybody who's been on
drugs
and wanted to do something tried to do
something i've been in that position
before
with friends with family members where
you see what's going on but you're
helpless in a lot of ways to intervene
you can do what you can but ultimately
the other person
you know is always going to be able to
run away because you can't physically
restrain them and then also babysit them
24 hours a day or you can even get them
to rehab and then it's not going to work
because if they're not
committed themselves
to being sober then what can you do you
know keep bringing them back to rehab i
mean you know rehab's expensive it's
thousands and thousands and thousands of
dollars in most cases and
who's paying for that does the person
uh you know
do they want to get sober for themselves
is that the most important thing or
do you think the influence of friends
and family can actually trump that
let me know let me know what you think
because i think it's a complicated issue
it delves into the psychology that we
like to talk about here um you know of
like
free will motivation substance abuse
substance addiction
um the notion of wanting to do something
for yourself because that's an analogy
that i
use for
losing fat for gaining muscle if you're
doing it for somebody else or somebody
shaming you and do that that's a very
short-sighted approach right
you can't just get buffed to impress a
girl it's just not going to work you're
not going to ever have enough motivation
over the long term you know to make a
girl like you over the course of years
because also you're going to develop
self-esteem along the way i think if you
if you lift enough weights and realize
this is a stupid goal to begin with so
in all those situations that i'm
outlining like you feel fat and you want
to lose weight and you know or maybe
somebody made fun of you like fat
shaming works to a degree if that person
already
values being skinny right if they have
been skinny in the past and you're like
shaming them be like hey this isn't you
go back to you okay maybe that'll work
but like if you've been fat your whole
life or
you know
drug addiction is the only thing that
you find solace in then it's gonna be
hard just to like you can't just walk up
to a crack at it and be like dude you
know stupid you look smoking crack like
get a hold of yourself it's like that
crack addict's not gonna be like damn
you're right i do look really stupid
smoking crack oh this is bad for my
health i didn't realize it before
wait are you telling me that spoken
crack is bad for your health
[Music]
i never realized dude
we have so many this is why we can't
have babies i've never seen this many in
the rundown
bonkers this is why we can't have nice
tips
there are so many reasons why we can't
have nice gyms
you're just an hour long did i
did i just put my own youtube yeah i was
like hour-long videos
okay
look i might have slept in my own
youtube channel
twice what the [ __ ] is going on i have
no idea
obviously i did all these drunk okay
here we have a guy he's about to squat
or he just finished a squat with what
looks to be about 500 pounds
and on the way up he hits off the things
that he would rack it in both at the
same time this is amazing just as far as
like what's the odds of that happening
you know he hits it perfectly where it's
like boom and then they both fall off
now people are making this big deal out
of it like like oh my god
it's like drop it on the ground dude
just dump it drop it on the ground and
did i talk about it last week
where i s where i talked about um
like how this dude is talking to me and
like i had to like
rack uh
uh no i must have not this this
i just told this story to other people
okay
um
i had to bail a squat like
in 24-hour fitness not on the
lifting platforms it's really bad like i
hate doing it you know but i just got
distracted by something
somebody talking to me and they'd
already
they were
while i was doing a warm-up set with 315
on like the third rep this guy
was like
one more let's go and i'm like
i like i angered me so
disproportionately
casey's like um
mark i'm noticing a theme here yeah well
you're getting really upset at the gym
yeah we're going to talk off air man
yeah
i uh
oh my god they're all oh it's an
intervention oh my god come on in guys
brendan tell george
mike you guys are all here to talk to me
about my anger issues um
but no it is it's loud and annoying but
like sometimes you have to do it so you
don't you know if the squats on your
back and you can't rack it you don't
just like fold under it
you let it go
and then say deal with it
okay
this is a montage of this guy trying 300
pounds and my thing is like why are you
trying this so many times and failing
one thing
my buddy griffin said about michael
hearn that i thought was interesting
he's like i've never seen him miss a
lift
because when you get really good at
lifting you know exactly how much you
can do and you see that it's it's a
total waste of time and energy
to put something on the bar just for the
arbitrary sake of saying i can bench
press 300 pounds and believe me i've
been there
because it was a very important
milestone for me to bend 300 pounds when
i was 12 years old now
this guy is obviously a fully grown
adult
and
but he got it he did get it in the end
so good for him but i'm just gonna
caution everybody against this type of
[ __ ] where it's like
you're just concerned about the number
and i just don't think it's productive i
remember i used to have a friend
who every time we went in he'd always
want to like max out i'm like
you're probably the same amount of
strong as you were last time though
because you haven't done anything and
you're also trying to lose weight and
like
you know you people get fixated and
fascinated with the idea of maxing out i
get it it's
been so long you know like i did do that
when i was like 16 or 17. and then you
just see that it's just a very
inefficient way to go up at the gym it's
not going to maxing out in and of itself
doesn't cause hypertrophy so you're
probably better off using that time that
you're going to use to max out on
actually doing some sets
right
and
nobody's ever going to ask you how much
you bench at a job interview unless the
job interview is to be a professional
power lifter which is not something that
exists because power lifters make no
money guys i'm sorry
this is pretty amazing and i'm impressed
that this guy put this on the internet
um
blake mattingly is his name now this is
like 700 pounds okay the dude's strong
as [ __ ]
it's one of these deadlifts that gets
almost up to that final point so crazy
how people fit it's like you can get
that off the ground but then
i guess you use so much energy
um and muscular tension to get it up to
past you know your kneecaps
that when you try to lock out you end up
going into a coma homeboy and the jorts
is like i'm gonna take this opportunity
and bang them
what's going on there dude he's like
yeah man i don't know i'll just put his
legs over my shoulder and insert my
penis i read it online
yeah it's like a you know jellyfish
thing you pee on your buddy yeah i know
deadlift you bang them when
a guy fails a deadlift and starts
twitching and goes into cardiac arrest
you put your penis in his [ __ ]
okay
now somebody sent me this i don't like
yeah this might just be on like a
regular dude's pa ah
no could be i
i'm trying to think can you go to this
guy's page sure and see how many
followers he has do whatever you want
buddy so okay so it was because this guy
i think
um
follows me or something he put that and
he's it's like has like let's go back to
the view count because this is making
the rounds
yeah it's like what
i mean i saw fifty nine thousand yeah
likes jesus and he's got like 10 posts
and again i just love these videos like
this because i love people in the gym
like
just to lack any sort of self-awareness
like this girl's humping
this
little
i don't know if it's a yoga mat or one
of these things that you stretch out on
but
you know i've never seen anybody do it
like that and it just looks like she's
rioting [ __ ] let's be honest
i squat three plates why
it's just
oh it's three plates all on one side
technically he's right he does squat
three plates
and at first i thought it was gonna be a
smith machine joke but now i see why
he's doing it because he couldn't
balance it if it was just an actual
barbell i think that's a great little
sketch there and it plays on how we use
words like that and how even like on the
smith machine i'm tempted to be you know
i posted a video of myself
repping i would have said 275 but it's
like well it's not a smith machine
though so you got to add that weight and
say what does the bar actually weigh but
most people will say like oh i was doing
225 in the smith machine and they're
talking about having two plates on there
even though it's not 225
and let's be honest some of the plates
of zoo culture do not weigh 45 pounds so
if you're at zoo culture saying you dead
lifted or benched a certain amount of
weight you might want to get a scale out
don't lift weights on a trampoline they
said oh he did it and then boom
the weights fly off and hit him in the
shin or the foot or whatever and it's
just again one of those things where hey
you asked for it bro
and that hurts dude getting a 45 pound
plate in the shin or whatever 10 pound
plate doesn't matter
casey knows what i'm talking about here
rollerblades for a living how many times
have you hit your shin oh my shins are
like once or twice
yeah seriously right yeah probably just
just resilient af okay this girl is
squatting now i like this whole setup
that it's like
she's squatting in like the garage the
mirror's there half of her foot is on to
this yoga mat right and she just slips
out right from underneath her and i go
like now
why is half your foot on there you know
like that's just things that i'd like i
would never do that like it's like would
you stand on a platform with one foot
and one not you know like
one butt cheeks on the bench as you're
doing shoulder press or something it's
just a weird thing to begin so that's
why that's how i justify putting these
gruesome injuries on my podcast is
because i go well i would have made a
different decision you know what i mean
calorie count and mother effers
after forgetting to add .003 milliliters
of toothpaste they accidentally
swallowed while brushing their teeth hop
up from bed
these calorie count effas that is true
though it is something where you don't
want to be obsessed with it and maybe
tristan lee would be another thing we
could get into next episode but he has
sort of publicly been dealing with his
body dysmorphia and his obsession
with getting his steps in with counting
his calories and getting to four percent
for god knows what reason other than
being a fitness influencer he's not a
competitive bodybuilder so why you would
put that yourself through that kind of
torture to get to not you know just like
ripped but four percent body fat he has
no body fat for what purpose i don't
know because getting there requires you
to be obsessed around the clock and
obviously that's some people's
temperament and personality and he's
moving away from that to like bulk quote
unquote and he probably still has like
you know he looks the same six seven
percent body fat and that's like him
being fat in the off season i guess but
it is a funny parody of that archetype
but i do think that's
it's an interesting little case study
and i think bodybuilding does tend to
draw those kind of people with like body
dysmorphia and obsessive personalities
um
you know that that end up kind of taking
in all our heads it's like oh that
person looks really healthy
but in reality it's not a very healthy
way to live because it's psychologically
torturous to constantly be thinking
about calories all day
so just be fat
pov the five pound container of protein
powder you just bought ends up tasting
bad
no greater sadness disappointment
frustration in the world
so what are you gonna do with that
protein powder throw it through the
window
it is i mean that has happened before
it's just like you know it's just like
this oh
why did i get the cinnamon toast crunch
flavor this tastes like crap
but usually it's with vanilla i remember
buying vanilla stuff i don't know if you
ever bought vanilla stuff in the 90s but
like vanilla flavor has come
so far since the 90s it used to take
like a
vanilla protein powder in the 90s tasted
like somebody had a vanilla ice cream
cone and threw it up and then put it in
a jar and dried form
there i said it okay
you know what i'm talking about
but now
oh
vanilla some of the best flavors out
there when the planet fitness employees
try to stop me from deadlifting what
happens dude i dare you good douche full
oh good douche
who wants some dude who wants to stop me
next go douche
are you allowed to do that to the
referee
he's is that a shamrock
the ken chan rock dude he's so juiced
out it's amazing
i say that like i'm not juiced out like
somebody looking at me
i was just really i was admiring his
physique because his lats are flared and
he looks pumped
this is another example of like hey
learn how to squat i even saw a dude at
the 24 fitness today who's like he's in
his 50s and he works there and like he
was squatting with three plates and it's
like you're just you're still squatting
highest giraffe balls i don't know how
you're going to be that old and be that
into fitness and work at a gym and be
there every day and like not know how to
squat all the way down because
at some point you just need to figure it
out
because it's people like this it's like
if you think you can load up a bar with
that much weight like really the danger
is of a whether it's a free weight or a
smith machine squat
if you can't handle that weight all the
way down
then you're gonna pass a certain point
by accident and end up breaking your
neck like that right this guy gets
folded in half and it's hilarious
because he does have the mobility to
handle that kind of
collapse
but it's like
obviously you didn't squat down to full
depth or anywhere close to that with a
lesser weight before doing that
so again i'm justifying gruesome
injuries here
based on the fact that i would make
different decisions
do you have any more is that it no dude
that was like a thousand
aside from your two carefully placed
references
oh oops another advertisement for my oak
and stone podcast
so crazy that that would happen in the
middle of all this
so my message to you to everybody out
there is if if you're in a bad mood
i want you to go to the 24 hour fitness
go to your local gym
hit a weight workout hit a sauna
get on the stairmaster
and then you're still probably going to
be in a bad mood and be a prick to
people afterwards okay it may not change
anything but
then you'll have a fun story to talk
about the next day and provide comedic
relief to other people and just
normalize
being in kind of a bad mood and not
being nice to everyone all the time even
if they're coming up to you and saying
things like oh my god you're so handsome
are you an actor you can be like
[ __ ] you dude i don't have time for this
combo right now all i have time for is
to sit in the sun and get buff
i'm a selfish narcissistic bodybuilder
get over it um
guys i just want to encourage you
if you see me in a gym
okay
don't ask me have you ever thought about
acting
ask me
how are you such a good actor there we
go
you